[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna burn this place to the ground
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
last night during Super Bowl 54 as
Marvel fans we were treated to an
absolutely incredible night not only did
we get a brand new TV spot for the Black
Widow movie coming out in May with a ton
of new footage but we also got our very
first look at not one not two but three
of Marvel's new shows that are going to
be coming to Disney Plus the Falcon and
the Winter Soldier series the one
division series and even briefly at the
end the Loki series and all of them look
absolutely fantastic they all look like
they're going to be movies so if you
were worried about how these movies were
actually going to be hopefully this
makes you feel a little bit better
because these all look awesome and in
this TV spot there's actually a ton of
major details about all of these
upcoming series specifically about the
Wanda vision series as they just packed
a ton of information in the new footage
that they showed us and there are five
major things that were revealed during
this new footage in this big game TV
spot that you need to know about the
Wanda vision series and I'm gonna break
it down and tell you everything that you
need to know I'm still doing my Xbox one
and ps4 giveaway all you have to do to
enter is subscribe when notifications
turned on like this video and comment
down below so here's the first thing
that you need to know about this new
footage that you saw and about the
upcoming one division series and the
first thing is is that all of the
footage that was shown to us is fake no
not fake like the Avengers infinity war
and Avengers in game trailers that were
shown to us but fake us in the world
that she is currently living in and this
show isn't real
this is actually an alternate reality
created for Wanda this reality was
created to be the perfect world for
Wanda this is exactly what Wanda has
always wanted out of life she's wanted a
husband she's wanted a family she's
wanted a nice suburban home she wants a
perfect life and that's exactly what she
has in this trailer and again that's
because it's a reality created
specifically for her and this is
actually shown when we see vision when
we see him for the very first time he
says Wanda welcome home now some people
think that this is simply Wanda going
out and still being an Avenger she goes
out does her job and then comes home but
that is not the case this is vision
welcoming Wanda to her perfect
to reality and not to mention if you
look at the clothes they're wearing
they're very 1950s and that's because
this is going to take place through
multiple different points of time and at
the time we're looking at right now it's
1951 des was definitely not an Avenger
during the 1950's and in the 1950s most
women were housewives so this is
definitely vision welcoming her to her
dream world but just because it's her
perfect reality doesn't mean that it's
going to last forever in fact it looks
like they show a picture very very fast
of Wanda discovering that this reality
may not be all what she thinks it is now
there's one of two people that most
likely created this alternate reality
for Wanda the first person is Wanda
herself and she's actually done this in
the comics and she's actually been known
to have psychological breakdowns when
she experiences great loss and that's
exactly where she's at after the events
of Avengers end games she lost vision
and then before in age of Ultron she
lost her brother Quicksilver so wonder
herself could have very well created
this reality but the other person who
was more likely to have created it is
Agatha Harkness in the comics Agatha is
actually a magical tutor to the Scarlet
Witch however she has been known to mess
with Wanda's reality she's a very
powerful witch and at one point in time
she erases Wanda's memory of her
children she then goes on later to
restore those memories and in fact we
already have leaked photos of Kathryn
Hahn as a witch most likely
Agatha Harkness so it seems that Agatha
is most likely the one that creates this
perfect world for Wanda and that brings
us to the second thing that you need to
know about this new footage that's been
shown to us and the second reason is
that there is some serious time travel
in this trailer if you look at Wanda and
vision sometimes you'll notice that she
changes many different outfits and many
different styles this is because the
Wanda vision series is going to jump
through various points in time and
although the time periods that they're
going to primarily be in aren't
officially confirmed yet it's widely
believed that it's going to take place
between the 1950s and the 1980s and if
we take a look at the scenes from the
trailer and we look at her clothes and
her hairstyles that seems to be what
it's going to be one that goes from
dressing like she's in the 1950s and
it's in black and white to dressing like
she's in the 60s almost wearing somewhat
of a hippie dress and you'll notice that
it's also now in color and then
looks like they go to the 1990s at the
end based off of their dress style this
actually kind of looks like it's a Boy
Meets World episode very 90s vibe and
the reason that there's going to be many
different time periods in the one
division series is because of that
alternate reality it's going to shift
time periods to be Wanda's perfect world
so we're going to see many different
things and probably a lot of references
and callbacks in the 1 division series
and coming back to this alternate
reality it brings us to number three and
that is vision now it's called the one
division series so of course everybody
knew that vision would be back
however vision is actually not alive in
any of the scenes that we see and if you
noticed he's actually in his Android
form the whole entire time despite us
seeing promo art official promo art from
Marvel Studios of him as a human but
vision actually isn't alive because he
is part of this alternate perfect
reality created for Wanda and of course
in this perfect reality her former lover
vision is alive and you may have noticed
that in one of the scenes that was shown
to us on this new footage everything is
black and white except for Wanda and
that's because she is real that's why
she's in color but everything else
including vision is in black and white
and of course this is because they are
not real but it looks like Wanda is kind
of discovering that in this scene that
we see Wanda is looking at a television
and she sees herself and we already know
that the Wanda vision series is going to
be kind of like a sitcom but it almost
appears as if Wanda herself is going to
be watching her perfect life as if it
were a sitcom she's inside of it and
she's living it but she can also tell
that it's not real and in this scene
right here it kind of seems like she's
coming to her senses and realizes my
environment isn't real and vision isn't
as well and this brings us into the
fourth major thing that you need to know
about this new footage and that is Wanda
and visions kids now you may have missed
this part because the footage went
pretty quickly but you can notice in one
scene that Wanda is pregnant
so clearly Wanda and vision are going to
have kids but remember it's an alternate
reality in which time is going to move
forward very quickly so we flash forward
to another scene where Wanda and vision
actually have kids they have two twin
boys wicken and speed we can see in the
scene there are two cribs down below and
we can see
twin simultaneously spit their pacifiers
out go in about three to four foot in
the air and this is because Wiccan and
speed are no ordinary children and to be
fair if you're the child of an extremely
powerful witch and an Android you're
probably not going to be to normal but
Wiccan and speed are actually major
characters and they're a part of The
Young Avengers in the comics Wiccan has
magical abilities just like his mother
and speed inherited the powers of his
uncle Quicksilver so we run super fast
and here in the one division series
we're going to be introduced to Wiccan
and speed now as I mentioned before
Agatha Harkness at one point in time in
the comics erases Wanda's memory of her
two children this is because Juana
doesn't exactly have the best of luck
when it comes to being a mother in the
comics she wants more than anything to
be a mother and when she finally does
have children she figures out that they
aren't really hers they were actually
missing shards of the soul of the demon
master pandemonium and pandemonium ends
up absorbing them back into himself
causing Wanda to lose her children and
this is most likely what we're leading
towards in the Wanda vision series
Wanda is going to have her perfect world
she'll have her perfect life with her
husband and her two children but then
it's all going to go away at some point
in time she will realize that this
reality is fake vision isn't real and
her kids in fact aren't real and this
could possibly and probably lead to her
exploding in the comics she would
actually end up attacking the Avengers
and the x-men would go on to create an
alternate reality called House of M and
it seems like this is what the series is
going to lead towards as it's going to
tie in to Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness it could be Wanda
that snaps after realizing that her
husband and her children aren't real and
in doing so creates multiple different
realities therefore busting open the
multiverse and this could be how she
ties into Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness and of course the
fifth thing that I'm sure everybody has
seen by now is that we finally see the
Scarlet Witch in her true comic costume
now I hate to say it but this isn't
really what you think it is this is
actually Wanda's Halloween costume there
was actually a leaked audition video for
the one division series for the role of
one of her sons and in this video we can
hear her son talking about Halloween and
going trick-or-treating in this video we
hear him talking about the costume that
he's going to wear so
fortunately it looks like Wanda's going
to be going trick-or-treating with her
sons and she's going to be going as
ironically a witch and as witch costume
is going to be her comic accurate
Scarlet Witch outfit so that's what
we're seeing with this new footage
however it doesn't mean that we're not
going to see her actually wear this
outfit in the one division series while
she becomes the true Scarlet Witch
because it has been confirmed by Marvel
that they are going to address her as
finally in this series as the Scarlet
Witch and if she does in fact snap after
finding out that everything isn't
actually real she could Don the outfit
from there on out but we'll have to wait
and see what happens to see if it's more
than just a costume so that's everything
that you need to know about the new
footage that we saw for the one division
series I'll be breaking down the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier in the brief Loki
footage that we got as well in a video
tomorrow be sure to let me know what you
thought about all this new footage that
we got for the three new Marvel Disney
Plus shows coming which one are you most
excited about and did you notice
anything else about the Wanda vision
footage that was shown be sure to let me
know in the comments down below and
again don't forget to subscribe and
notifications turned on and leave a like
on the video so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or ps4 as always thank you all so much
for watching we'll fluff